[Music]
have you guys gone out into public rang
guess this isn't public this is our
office this is like we know we've
quarantine Rahel I'm quite the isolated
man yes are we
but like public spaces groceries yes and
forgotten your mask at home
Oh yesterday I got Taco Bell mm-hmm and
then what I was getting it I was like oh
oh I'm so sorry and I put the mask on oh
nice good they were just like yeah I
leave my mask hanging on the rearview so
I always have it if I'm a horse remember
yeah I have a pair of pants that I did
forget mask and I tied the pair of pants
are on my head my head honestly and it
won't work
oh really never like what the crotch
part or on your nose yeah the only way
to do it was it was actually better
coverage that I've experienced with the
mask cuz it's like covering [ __ ]
everything she was like just end you tie
it tighter yeah have you seen the guy
with the glass pot cover cuz he ran he
didn't have his mask but you had to go
get some [ __ ] so he had his hoodie right
he put the glass block cover over like
this and then he tied his baby I love it
yeah dude for a while mass was so sold
out that people had to resort to kind of
this kind of [ __ ] I've also seen people
just with no masks to but when I'm in
the supermarket I'm sure I haven't seen
anyone like get kicked out of a place
we're not wearing a mask place is that
going to have been pretty chill but like
I forgotten it a couple of times and
like I'm like I was walking to the post
office right and I was like I'm gonna
just send this letter and walk into the
post office and then as they got closer
started seeing all the goo of mass and
what oh [ __ ] can I turn back home in
Ukraine a woman went to the post office
and this happened she got tackled what
wait watch took off my pants shoes are
huge service at the post office not
[Music]
that is amazing
oh those pants that she took off so let
me stand there with my vagina hanging
out I know no one else is looking at her
like you've never been around a lazy
person man you don't want to stir it to
their eyes in your their next target
sure true maybe they're like I wish I
had like streaks - oh God
this is Ukraine baby Ukraine yeah it was
a period day I don't think she would
have done that true true
unless she was wearing a tampon good
point thank you welcome the tampons
really work that well it's just like
literally everything just stays clogged
in there yeah yeah you got to change it
cuz it'll soak it up kind of like it's
like that literally like camp on your
nose but you see how it's getting filled
up so fit if you don't take it out fast
enough then it gets full and then there
yeah can you feel what it's good no
until it's too late
yeah so it's not like a nose what do you
mean no the feelings of the nose you
know like when it's when it's too late
yeah it's already in there yeah and by
the time you feel it like Bloods already
coming why it's not like a fountain it
doesn't fall out it's just like it's
like for these things before there's
some thats a heavy flow so I know that
some are like fountains no it's a
thicker it's just more and it's just a
bigger no like have you ever seen a
nosebleed go like Shh yeah but I've seen
in commercials when they compared to
prep tampon brands together they use a
whole picture you're talking about a pad
we're talking about tampons this is a
tampon a pad is the thing we did the
experiment on true so do you like tap
pads or pad ties or do you like tampons
what's your heart tired all day tampons
oh why she's a bad person I know well
the thing is that like whatever time
won't make me feel uncomfortable like I
would start actually get stomachaches at
m5 but like I don't leave it in for long
I don't leave it in for that long
because because you have the time period
of like four to six hours and I take it
out at four but then after some time
like my body just doesn't like it and it
starts like hurting and sounds like [ __ ]
I gotta go back to my pads so like I go
on my pad and it just chills out this
was the conversation that I didn't even
know I needed I think but now you know
thank you yeah yeah I was trying to like
talk about post offices and stuff no she
brought it up yeah you probably know
things on the pad and it's taste here
underwear I experimented with my mom's
talking about the wings I don't know I
was little and I saw what this is okay
it's cuz my mom I thought all girls they
have problems like keen like like peeing
on themselves I thought like sometimes
they leak cuz they don't got a dick so
they do sometimes I've heard girls on
when they laugh can leak for sure yeah
if you have to push really are
deadlifting sexy as we once thought is
it well some guys might find that second
while I control this shower sparked says
the showers yep alright well I want to I
also put the my mom's pad on my indoor
before I peed in it you peed on yourself
yeah you just test you just had wet
pulse oh no it's like you know when
you're home alone and you not have
anything to do so you just start
searching all over the house for stuff
yep and then I'm all quarter these
sticky flaps you know also that's how it
stays in place and I put it on those all
ball G and I just started peeing into it
I've been all along a lot as a kid and I
never got into my mom's underwear drawer
you have siblings truth yeah we all
never did that though really
you never got curious I never got
curious I got into my mom's make up my
things like oh I was so curious in my
dad's my god hahaha if you had makeup I
get all up in it
the only me ever got curious about wear
heels and they were just kind of there's
I don't you just flip them on you have
to do the whole hip shoulder if you
don't know how to walk in heels I know
it as girls go robot yeah and they're
just kind of like waddle I don't know
did you get in trouble for looking at
your parents [ __ ] yeah yes I probably
did but I suppressed those memories man
my dad had a Taser in his sock drawer
wet and I took it out and just in a
[ __ ] put my finger on it and it was
all as you turn it on hit the ground
immediately
did ya that's why you didn't play with
it do you remember or what did you like
we've come to ago what the hell I think
that I didn't quite touch it all the way
it was enough whatever I did it did not
[ __ ] me up yeah I remember hitting the
ground and then being scared shitless
and then just not saying anything I
never told anybody about it
he put it back put it back they didn't
they didn't catch you no thank you
all the [ __ ] that happened that like
your parents have no [ __ ] idea or
like when you become parents and all
this [ __ ] they're gonna do and you have
no idea
my mom saw overprotective that like when
I was home she would call every 30
minutes or every hour from her work
didn't stop you from [ __ ] the lamp no
I did it [ __ ] at lamp that today we
learn to heal up you [ __ ] the lamp so
once did you burn you forgot about that
so you know you know it never came up
again yeah you never asked me about so
I'm going to tell you you know how
couples we tell each other like who who
are sexual partners were Bart never told
you about the lamp Hey and you guys
thought I was the only inanimate object
[ __ ]
apparently Bart likes to climb taller
thing I need that one oh also not part
of it so like I climbed a trees and I
climbed poles and I had my first orgasm
when I was like four years old remember
and then I started to realize it's so
inconvenient every time I want to jack
up on something
to go outside and install all Asian
households have that lamp that's skinny
that goes like this and opens like this
right and it has a fader you probably
have one yeah and so what I would do is
I would take that and I would take it
away from the wall a little bit and lean
it on the wall and I would start
climbing that it's like a bust a little
nut and then the things started bending
over time when my mom's I wisest lap
keep bending and breaking music oh like
I need to get rid of this laughing
you're like no wait no no let me talk to
her got a new laughs cause it kept
bending and you're like who's this
you're like oh hi welcome but yeah so
this this lady she is a mother of two so
she's not a crazy person she's just a
house mom with the mission to send out
some letters or whatever it was
I mean your mom in public what did you
just do this unless it was a TV if it
was at the DMV and I already waited
hours and now it's my turn I'm doing oh
yeah if you've been there for hours [ __ ]
but underwear oh yeah that's largest
pants or ya know it'd be underwear maybe
sock if I have long it's too soft
maybe my bra it's like I'm not gonna
there's a lot of choices there's a lot
of choice you put her pants back on me
she's a decent woman I don't know if I
would want to put on my underwear on my
face you only say admitting that you're
nasty dude I'm a [ __ ] gross human
being I love you she doesn't give a [ __ ]
I'll go and get the face basket my Clark
come back hmm we get the TV home up
you're not gonna they're not they won't
have the funny kids tried to do this yet
would they just walk out around like
this
yeah I know I bet funny kids to try to
do it though the kids were are super
funny they're like they're really funny
yeah so nice a person yeah yeah yeah
[Music]